[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday september 1st i'm zoe thomas
for the wall street journal
a first of its kind bill passed
unanimously in california this week
it would require social media platforms
like facebook snapchat and tick tock to
consider the physical and mental health
of minors when designing their products
after the bill passed supporters spoke
outside the state house about its
potential impact
among them was 18 year old emmy kim from
logoff a teen-led organization
supporting the bill
kim said she faced online bullying as a
teenager
safety parameters exist on everything
that kids touch except social media
social media was not designed for
children it was designed for adults
it's now time you design it for us
the bill now heads to the desk of
california governor gavin newsom he
hasn't said if he'll sign or veto it and
a spokesperson declined to comment
but how much of an impact can this one
state level law have
and is it a sign of more regulation on
social media to come
joining us to discuss this is our tech
reporter megan bobarowski hi megan
thanks for coming back on the show hi
zoe
so let's start with what exactly is in
this bill
sure so this bill would make it so that
social media companies going forward
would have to keep the well-being of
children in mind when they're designing
products and features that children are
likely going to access
children being defined as anyone under
the age of 18. and so how would social
media companies be expected to do that
and be held accountable for doing that
so the social media companies would have
to do a risk assessment basically
assessing whether their products do harm
children and then they'd have to submit
that report to the government and if the
government at any point finds that they
are in violation of this rule you know
they do have features that are you know
harmful to children they have 90 days to
fix the problem to you know address the
feature or
shift the algorithm and if they don't
complete that in 90 days then they are
subject to fines of up to 7 500 a child
which you know if you have potentially
hundreds of thousands of children on
these apps that's a lot of money yeah i
can see that working out to be a
potentially pretty hefty fine one thing
when i uh kind of glanced through what
was in the bill that stood out to me was
this requirement that their privacy
policies be in language that children
can understand i mean how did they
determine that and are we going to
expect children to read these privacy
rules any more than we expect adults to
so a lot of this i think is not clearly
spelled out as in this is the language
you need and here's what you're gonna do
but there's very similar laws that have
been enacted in europe in the uk and so
this bill is actually very much based on
uk law and so you can sort of look to
that to see the types of things that
might be targeted here so for instance
in the uk google has to make safe search
which screens out any sort of
inappropriate content they have to make
that their default setting for children
and tick tock and instagram
have disabled direct messaging between
children and adults they do not follow
on the platform so it's things like this
that you can sort of look to as examples
of ways that the companies might have to
tweak or alter the way they operate and
it's actually the way they do operate
abroad
how are the social media companies
reacting to this bill passing so
representatives from
meta snap twitter have lobbied against
the spill they did not want it to pass
there's a group called technet that
lobbies on behalf of these tech groups
and they oppose the bill and they say
that you know because it's at the state
level this is going to create problems
for them in terms of you know they don't
operate at a state level they operate
nationally and internationally and so
having what they call a patchwork of
different laws in different states will
make it really hard for them to regulate
and do what they need to do but you know
this law
has already been basically enacted in
the uk and so they actually are already
doing some of this
abroad can you just take us briefly
through how we got to this point i mean
this wasn't the first bill of its kind
to try and pass in california
yeah so there have been a slew of social
media bills that have been
going through the legislature there was
one that died last month that would have
allowed
state attorneys general to sue the
companies if they believed they were
harming children so the social media
companies
preferred this one that has passed it's
a bit more lenient you know it's not
like anyone's going to be suing them
over this
they still oppose it but they previously
said you know that they wanted
this bill over potentially any other
bills that would allow either the state
or parents even there's at one point
there was a bill that would have allowed
parents to sue the social media
companies they obviously were not in
favor of that okay so this is a law on
the state level people have called for
more federal action we've certainly been
hearing about the impact of social media
for a couple of years do we expect other
states to follow this precedence up by
california or for the federal government
to step in and do anything
certainly you have some people who are
saying this needs to happen on the
federal level and are advocating for
that but you know california is really
the leader here and the proponents of
the bill say if we can pass this here
sometimes california does it first and
the rest of the country follows and so i
think the sort of thought process for
the proponents of this bill is if we
pass it here then other states will see
this and pass their own versions of that
whereas the opponents say no let's do
one at the federal level which might be
more difficult to pass but actually in
california this bill had bipartisan
support so actually maybe not
so what comes next i mean when can we
expect to possibly see changes to these
platforms so the bill still needs to be
signed by governor newsome and he has
not said whether or not he will sign the
bill
but if the governor signs the bill and
it goes into law these provisions
requiring social media companies
to design their platforms with children
in mind will go into effect in july 2024
and so
any features or platforms or anything
created after that will be subject to
these laws but you know anything that
exists if they run the assessment and
say
this doesn't pass our tests you know
this isn't okay they would then have to
make those changes
all right that's our reporter megan
bobrowski thanks for joining us megan
thanks for having me and that's it for
today's tech news briefing
if you want more tech stories check out
our website
wsj.com and if you enjoy listening to
our show please leave us a five star
rating and a review on apple podcast
spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you